reportage et après Monsieur
Paulette. On parle de l'ampleur
de la bonne nouvelle, mais
- Vous voyez, tout ce qui est
noir, des taches noires,
ce sont des métastases,
Alors, vous voyez, ce patient-là
en a beaucoup, mais il risque de
bénéficier de ce médicament-là.
- Le docteur Fred Saad
s'enthousiasme au sujet
de pointe approuvée par
Santé Canada pour le traitement
des graves cancers
de la prostate.
Dr FRED SAAD, directeur- Ça dont
à des patients qui ont presque
perdu tout espoir de voir
prolonger leur survie et de
maintenir leur qualité de vie.
la thérapie radioligand.
D'abord, on scanne
très précisément le cancer
du patient. Puis, on lui injecte
Un radioligand est composé
de reconnaître les cellules
cancéreuses du patient,
de se fixer sur elles
et de relâcher une particule
radioact
les détruire. Tout ça,
sans endommager le
en santé.
- C'est le genre de traitement
dont on rêvait : de pouvoir
prendre un patient et viser
- En moyenne, la thérapie
permet de réduire e réduire e r%
la progression des métastases,
les chances de survie
du patient. Et parfois,
spectaculaires.
de la prostate depuis 22 ans.
i tous les traitements
possibles, standards
et expérYVAN LANIEL, 78 ans
- Tout ce que j'ai
toujours fonctionné, seulement
que c'était temporaire.
- En 2018, les métastases
En dernier recours, on lui offre
une thérapie radioligand.
La magie opère rapidement.
Dès le premier traitement,staset
et, 18 mois plus tard,ard,ard,a,
elles ont toutes disparu.
Là, j'ai compris que c'était
vrai, puis c'était sérieux,
mais je ne savais pas combien
de temps ça durerait.
- Alors que pour la majorité
des patients, la rémission est
temporaire, pour Y
elle se poursuit.
- Là, à ma grane,
bien, je suis dans les 2 %
qui ont le mieux réagi au
er à un miracle.
- Maintenant que la thérapie est
approuvée pour les graves cas de
cancer de la prostate, on espère
qu'elle permettra de traiter
des cancers moins avancés.
si on l'amène plus tôt,
est-ce que ça sera encore plus
efficace? Mais la contrepartie,e
que c'est sécuritaire.
- Rappelons que pour l'instant,
cette thérapie n'est rembourséeé
au Canada.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon